hallo herzlich willkommen denn meine
torten welt heute werde ich eine
regenbogen torte machen
ich habe euch gestern abend per facebook
und instagram des bilder vom gepostet
und ich war sehr überrascht wie viele
kommentare und bewertungen abgegeben
habt und wie oft das bild überhaupt
geteilt wurde
ich hatte gestern abend richtig große
reichweite erreicht und ich weiß echt
überwältigt dass es bei euch so gut
ankommt deswegen habe ich mich dazu
beschlossen euch auch sofort das video
dazu zu liefern damit ihr alles sofort
die torte nach machen kannst ich werde
dazu einen zitronenkuchen rezept nehmen
einfach damit ich jetzt nichts neues
macht und weil mir persönlich der
zitronenkuchen natürlich auch am besten
schmeckt ich bin im märz und zitronen
mensch die rezepte könnt ihr wie immer
auf meinem blog nachlesen auf
www.cenit.de ich werde ich jetzt
trotzdem einmal zeigen was ihr an
zutaten benötigt und wenn ich dann noch
ein paar informationen geben an zutaten
braucht ihr sechs eier 200 gramm
puderzucker 100 milliliter wasser das
mineralwasser 120 gramm öl und 60
milliliter zitronensaft und etwas
zitronenschale
also ich werde erst die schale abreiben
und stand 60 milliliter zitronensaft
ausdrücken
ihr braucht 150 gramm mehl 150 gramm
stärke und eine packung backpulver
zuerst kommen jetzt die eier in einer
rührschüssel die lasse ich jetzt früher
und gebt dann nach und nach den
puderzucker mir dazu und dann lasse ich
das ganze verrühren bis es eine richtig
schöne dicke cremige masse
so krems sollte die masse dann zum
schluss aussehen
und jetzt kann ich auch die maschine weg
stellen und den rest werde ich nämlich
per hand unterrühren
da gebe ich jetzt meine öl und meine
flüssigkeiten rein als mein wasser
stehen zitronensaft denen ich in der
zwischenzeit schon ausgedrückt habe dann
die zitronenschale und jetzt nach mail
speisestärke und backpulver das habe ich
alles schon gesiebt und kann das jetzt
einfach hier mit dazugeben und das habe
ich jetzt ganz sorgfältig unter wenn der
teig fertig ist muss eltmann portioniert
werden
ich möchte meine regenbogen torte mit
sechs schichten machen
deswegen werde ich den teil geht es in
sechs teile portionieren und wie ich das
mache zeige ich euch jetzt bin ich es
dann soweit habt bereitet ihr schon mal
eure springform vor ich habe jetzt diese
20 zentimeter wakana jetzt habe ich hier
schon vorbereitet als ich hier mein
fertige teig hier habe ich sechs
schlüssel in denen ich gleich den teig
aufteilen werde
und hier habe ich verschiedene farben
ich benutzt die farben von wilden ja
nicht mehr
das sind jetzt andere farben die bekommt
ihr dann in meinem shop jetzt kann man
bei mir an der glasschüssel ganz gut
ablesen und zwar stehen hier die
maßangaben hier steht jetzt zwölf karts
auf der rückseite steht 2 liter ihr
könnt den teig aber auch ganz gut auf
eine waage stellen als in der andere
schüssel wiegen und einfach abwägen weil
ihn jetzt exakt in sechs portionen
aufteilen löst tempo zurecht und es mit
den caps finde ich ganz praktisch weil
ich so kaps mir mal gekauft hatte das
heißt zwölf cups durch sex gibt zwei
karts ein cup umfasst etwa 250
milliliter
das heißt ihr könnt es zum beispiel auch
mit einem glas machen welches 250
milliliter fassungsvermögen
ihr könnt es aber wie gesagt auch
einfach abwägen und den teig durch sechs
teilen und dann in die kleinen
schüsselchen abgeben
jetzt müsst ihr euch nur noch überlegen
wie er den teig einfärben wollt ich
möchte keinen klassischen regenbogen
kuchen machen sondern mal eine andere
farbe nehmen
ich nehme jetzt dafür hier diese farben
ich habe hier oben und knalliges pink
dann in orange gelb ein helles grün und
türkis und ein lila ihr könnt aber
natürlich auch rot gelb orange blau
violett nehmen
das sind die typischen regenbogenfarben
und die muss ich mir jetzt wie gesagt
aus meinem passten farben
zuerst möchte ich jetzt den pink tor
machen und dafür nehme ich auch mein
pink dafür nehmt ihr euch jetzt einen
sauberen löffel oder einen zahnstocher
und geht dann auch nur einmal in diese
passte damit rein
ich probierte jetzt erstmal aus also nur
eine ganz kleine spitze davon
ihr seht mit so einer kleinen spitze
bekomme ich so ein ganz leichtes
babyrosa also verwende ich jetzt schon
etwas mehr
da nehme ich mein orange für die
orangene farbe
jetzt komme ich zu dem teilen den wohl
die meisten interessant finden und zwar
zu meinem farbstoffen
ich finde der nicht mit die farbstoffe
von wilson ich wusste einfach nicht dass
die gesundheitsgefährdend sein können
in lebensmittelfarben stecken nämlich
azofarbstoffe die machen die farben so
richtig schön kräftig und leuchtend und
mir war das einfach nicht bewusst bis
ihr mich darauf aufmerksam gemacht hat
und ich nicht daneben damit mal befasst
habe ich habe es einen hersteller
gefunden einen deutschen hersteller der
auch lebensmittelfarben herstellt das
sind eben diese hier und ich war auch
schon in der produktion wird dabei und
habe mich mit dem hersteller unterhalten
die farbstoffe enthalten auch
azofarbstoffe aber diese azofarbstoffe
die hier enthalten sind liegen einfach
deutlich unter den grenzwerten die es in
der eu und in deutschland gibt und das
hat mich dann wirklich so ein bisschen
beruhigt weil ich einfach weiß dass sich
diese farben benutzen kann und diese
unbedenklich sind bei den rücken farben
ist es einfach so dass die wirklich
deutlich die grenzen überschreiten und
ich die auch gar nicht mehr benutzen
möchte ich habe es ja auch mittlerweile
alle schon entsorgt weil ich einfach
dieses risiko nicht eingehen möchte
gerade wenn ich trocken für andere
machen
möchte ich diese farben nicht mehr
benutzen weil die azofarbstoffe
gesundheitsgefährdend sein können
das heißt sie können konzentrations und
aufmerksamkeitsstörungen bei kindern
hervorrufen und das sollte man
eigentlich vermeiden indem man einfach
farben nimmt die hier auch zugelassen
sind
bei den farben hatte ich am anfang ein
bisschen probleme damit weil ich gedacht
habe ich dann bestimmt da nicht so gut
und aber ich bin echt positiv überrascht
ich muss auch sagen die textur ist
richtig gut so richtig schöne passten
das heißt wenn ich die verbände
verändert sich die konsistenz eines
tages nicht weil die farben nicht
flüssig sind und auch ganz wichtig die
konsistenz des von dam mine von dort
bleibt trotzdem richtig schön fest das
hatte ich bei den wirten farben oft
nicht mehr so weil die ziemlich gematik
waren und weil schwarz zum beispiel war
schon fast für sich als ich weiß nicht
was die da gemacht haben
und schließlich es ihn richtig schöne
passten sie sind sehr ergiebig und sind
auch haltbar bis 2018 also die farben
sind fünf jahre haltbar
das heißt wenn ihr die einmal kauft und
ihr könnt ihr gar nicht aufbrauchen bis
2018 also und aus zeitlichen gründen
damit dieses video jetzt nicht extrem
lang wird schreibe ich euch einfach dazu
welche farben ich für welche teig
schicht benutzt habe damit ihr ausseht
welches eben die farbe ist es gibt
nämlich 28 farben und die sind alle
wirklich sehr unterschiedlich und ich
werde auch an 28 fragen in meinen videos
einfachen damit ihr einfach sehen könnt
wie sie wirken und welche leuchtkraft
sie haben system jetzt meine farben aus
und die müssen jetzt natürlich noch in
die form gebracht und gebacken werden
dann gebe ich den tag einfach in meinen
armen und dann wird es so bei 170 grad
etwa 10 bis 15 minuten gebacken
ihr müsst auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe machen und dann zeige ich euch wie
die einzelnen schichten aussehen so
sehen jetzt meine fertig gebackenen
böten aus die habe ich jetzt alles schön
abkühlen lassen und diese schönen blüten
müssen jetzt eben noch befüllt und
gestoppt werden um eine tortur
möchte ich heute eine zitronencreme
machen ich habe jetzt aber eine andere
kriegen genommen also keine garage
garage habe ich trotzdem hergestellt
weil ich dann später die torte mit gas
eindecken möchte und einstreichen möchte
für die creme braucht ihr 60 gramm
zucker eine zitrone davon den saft
eineinhalb esslöffel stärke ihr braucht
wasser und zwar so viel dass ihr dem
zitronensaft auf 125 gramm auffüllt ihr
braucht 400 gramm sahne und vier
teelöffel sammlerpaar das benutze ich
ganz gern weil es einfach eine schöne
freie methode ist die sahne etwas fester
zu bekommen
zuerst drücke ich jetzt die zitrone aus
und gibt es direkt in den topf und dabei
wie gehe ich ab wie viel gramm der
zitronensaft hat und findet es dann
später mit wasser auf jetzt könnt ihr
sehen ich habe zu 48 gramm zitronensaft
und fühlen dass jetzt auf 125 gramm
dann gebe ich jetzt noch die
speisestärke mit der zeit und den zucker
und rührt das ganze schön klümpchen frei
und dann wird es jetzt einfach auf
höchster stufe eingekocht und wenn es
dann einmal gekocht habt können das
schon ausmachen
denn damit dass auch direkt eingelegt
das ganze sieht am ziemlich schäbig aus
und dann fühle ich mir das in so ein
kleines schälchen um damit es hier schön
abkühlen kann und nehme mir dann etwas
frischhaltefolie und deckt es dann
direkt damit also direkt auf den pudding
sozusagen
und so gebe ich das in den kühlschrank
oder ihr könnt auch in die gefriertruhe
geben bis es vollständig abgekühlt ist
meine zitronencreme ist abgekühlt die
war etwa eine halbe stunde eben
gefrierfach und jetzt kann ich mich um
die sahne
dazu gebe ich jetzt einfach die 400
konzerne in meinen mix druck dazu
verwende ich meinen spritzschutz damit
dass jetzt nicht beim rühren raus
spritzt das ganze lasse ich jetzt ganz
langsam bis auf stufe acht oder zehn
kommen
und lass es schön eine halbe minute
schaumig rühren und dann gebe ich die
vier teelöffel st anna park mit dazu und
dann kommt da die creme mit rein
wenn die sahne halb steif ist die creme
dazu die habe ich jetzt eben schon
verrührt und lass es dann richtig steif
schlagen
und so sieht jetzt die fertige creme aus
und so werde ich jetzt die böden damit
befinden und schichten
dann nehmt ihr euch eine trocken platte
und den ersten boden dass bei mir der
liane boden dann nehme ich mir ein paar
backpapier streifen mein backpapier weil
er mich einfach papierstreifen legte
hier außen rum
damit meinen toren rahmen des gleich
nicht dreckig wird und dann nehme ich
mir meine creme und gibt da einfach ein
bisschen was trauer
wäre es einfacher machen möchte nimmt
sich einfach einen trockenen rand und
gibt den auswirkungen
dann nehme ich einfach so eine
verstellbaren genutzt ist einfach hier
ein streich
die creme sitz im kühlschrank wieder
etwas fest werden und etwas abkühlen
später werde ich die tore dann mit
ghanas einstreichen
es ist auch ganz wichtig dass er die
torte mit kanal strategie einfach damit
der form dann später nicht in berührung
mit der sahne creme kommt weil sich dann
davon dann nämlich auflöst und das
letztendlich schade um die dekoration
die wir später herstellen möchten
jetzt lasse ich die torte etwa eine
stunde im kühlschrank und sich dann wie
es weitergeht
jetzt kann ich den torten randhir
entfernen
hier könnt ihr jetzt so mal die farben
erkennen denn gleich wird er eingedeckt
und das mache ich jetzt mit einer ganz
normalen weißen garage die gebe ich
jetzt erstmal ringsrum an den rand
aus der leichten überschuss mit einer
tankkarte weg
dann kommt auch danach obendrauf
das ziehe ich jetzt einmal mit seiner
winkel palette ab
jetzt streicht einfach von außen innen
so sieht dann die torte fertig
eingestrichen aus und jetzt kann ich
hier unten das papier vorsichtig
wegnehmen sich jetzt weisen von dann mit
dem verzicht die torte
das wird meine grundlage dann habe ich
jetzt richtig gut durchgeknetet mit der
das palais und am besten rollt ihr
fondant auf etwas becker stärke aus das
ist nämlich viel besser als puder zu
kommen weil es einfach nicht so klebt
und die oberfläche schön macht bleibt
soll ich den von dann ganz locker hier
auf und kann den anheben und lege ihn
dann direkt über meine torte
jetzt streiche ich den hier schön glatt
von oben nach unten immer wieder von
dann anheben und mit den händen nach
unten aus streichen
und wenn ihr das dann soweit habt könnt
ihr das da unten am rand direkt
wegschneiden
und dann nehme ich mir jetzt hier meinen
seehofer meine blätter und glätte schön
die oberfläche rennt auf die seite
ich habe jetzt hier meine sechs farben
wieder vorbereitet das ist jetzt alles
von dort und das habe ich mit den
gleichen farben wieder ein gefährt mit
den passenden farben jetzt benutze ich
hier so ein ganz tolles werkzeug und
zwar kann ich darin vom band einführen
und er spritzt wird es dann hier vorne
raus und hier habe ich jetzt eine noch
auf satz drin
und seit ich das jetzt einfach mal ich
denke die wenigsten von euch kennen
dieses gerät ich glaub super dann heißt
es
und weil es eben nicht habt haben das
auch ganz normal per hand machen
dazu nehmen wir euch wieder etwas becker
stärke und rollt dann einfach den
fondant ihn so lange schlangen
die müssten halt dann ziemlich
gleichmäßig sein und weil ich mich
einfach die arbeit um die zeit ersparen
will
benutze ich da das gerät dazu dazu gebe
ich so ein kleines stück von dort hier
einfach oben rein dann kommt der aufsatz
wieder drauf und wenn ich jetzt da unten
drücke kommt diese schlange unten raus
jetzt hab ich mir das mal an meine torte
dran ob mir das von der dicke her
gefällt oder ob es eher etwas dünner
möchte so wie das aussehen wird auch
gehen aber ich werde etwas klüger machen
weil ich mehrere schichten haben möchte
jetzt jemand von jeder farbe zwei
stränge gespritzt und nur damit ihr mal
so ein zeitgefühl bekommt was wird das
für das hab ich jetzt eine halbe stunde
gebraucht weil es einfach lästig ist
ständig dieses ding hier aufzuführen
das ist einfach auch der nachteil dieses
werkzeugs dass ich einfach viel zu klein
das heißt ich muss ich musste nach zwei
strängen sowieso wechseln und wieder
auffüllen und deswegen habe ich jetzt
auch nur mal die farben gemacht damit
sie mir eben auch nicht austrocknen und
dafür nehme ich mir jetzt einfach etwas
zucker kleber und streicht ist hier am
rand an und dann beginne ich mit der
untersten farbe das ist dieser lila ton
liegt es einmal außen rum und drückst
einander torte fest und dann wird sie
weggeschnitten
und da einfach zu geklickt und dann
beginnen die am besten auch wieder da wo
die schnittstelle war
meine torte kennt er jetzt schon ich
habe jetzt hier einfach noch ein paar
buchstaben ausgestochen die werde ich
jetzt auf der torte dekorieren
die torte könnt ihr natürlich der
koffein wie ihr wollt also mich hat es
insgesamt so etwa vier bis fünf stunden
gedauert die torte herzustellen
schwierigsten oder am längsten dauert
halt immer die ganzen teile einzufärben
und die danach einander zu backen ich
habe auch weiter nur einen backofen
außerdem darauf ziemlich lange die
dekoration außen anzubringen
wer sich die zeit nehmen möchte ich
finde es lohnt sich die torte sieht
wirklich super aus
gerade diesen diese feinen ringe aus
warum finde ich ganz schön meine
schwester hat sich auch selber die torte
gefreut und sie hat uns allen sehr gut
geschmeckt ich hoffe dieses prozent
gefällt euch denn ihr hobby ist wirklich
mal aus ich werde demnächst auch mal
makros für euch machen das habe ich
jetzt auch schon versprochen und dann
eben mit der weihnachtsbäckerei auch
starten da freue ich mich auch schon
richtig drauf weil ich da auch richtig
idee keks dekoration gehe ich wünsche
euch jetzt noch einen ganz schönen
sonntag teilt video falls ihr euch
gefällt ihm eine bewertung über einen
kommentar freue ich mich unter 10 bis
zum nächsten mal wieder mit einem neuen
rezept des balls